well Democrats in Congress are set to  request documents today for more than 60  of president Trump's associates House  Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry  Nadler said that it is quote very clear  that the president obstructed justice  his committee is investigating possible  crimes by mr. Trump before and after he  was elected but Democrats want to avoid  talk about removing him from office  impeachment is a long way down the road  we don't we don't have the facts yet  this increasing can get congressional  scrutiny comes as Special Counsel robert  muller appears to be winding down his  russia investigation the president  blasted the Moller probe in a speech to  conservatives over the weekend you put  the wrong people in a couple of  positions and they leave people for a  long time that shouldn't be there and  all of a sudden they're trying to take  you out with bull okay now mr. Trump's  former fixer Michael Cohen is expected  to be back on Capitol Hill Wednesday